guardando il nostro paese quello che si
vede che diversamente dalla nord europa
l'italia è veramente il paese del sole
cioè tra le fonti rinnovabili
quella che ha il maggior potenziale me
tarja e il sole e mentre noi stiamo
parlando
ci sono aziende americane quindi dagli
stati uniti di trani private in un paese
in cui il gas posta circa la meta che
che da noi che stanno investendo montù
in impianti a gas
ma il solare fotovoltaico accoppiato un
grande sistemi di accumulo in portogallo
qualche mese fa un'impianto scala
industriale solare è stato affatto un
contratto per un centesimo e un 1,1
centesimo prima del povera borsa e rai3
in italia viaggiava oltre i cinque che
il costo che ottiene il gas quindi il
paese del sole
io non so perché noi continuiamo a
contare sul gas forse c'è qualcuno che
ha già fatto i contratti e vuole che lo
consumiamo il suo scenario già un sacco
di numeri alone che voglio tediare sui
numeri quello che voglio dirvi è che
oggi abbiamo 21 gigawatt di solare
installato nel nostro scenario al 2030
dovremo arrivare a 100 cioè il doppio
dell'attuale piano del governo sui tetti
di tutti gli edifici dai capannoni le
stime correnti
solo che ce la fanno il massimo 60
quindi bisognerà fare impianti a terra
ma qui c'è una polemica io trovo
ideologica persino nel governo che il
suo era terra non so perché i terreni
agricoli ora a parte lo diciamo come i
terreni agricoli sono classificate
sappiamo che ex discariche sono ancora
classificati con materiale qui non lo sa
ballare sa fare una pianificazione nel
territorio per capire se effettivamente
la descrizione la attribuzione di terna
greco corrisponde alla realtà ma non c'è
dubbio che invece il matrimonio tra
agricoltura e
roma né si può fare si chiama agri
voltaico e cioè è possibile produrre
agricoltura e produrre energia solare
perché siamo un paese densamente
popolato siamo un paese che non sa
deserti abbiamo poco territorio quindi
dobbiamo essere intelligenti ed è
possibile farlo si è possibile ho fatto
qui ci sono la fotografia anche intanto
dobbiamo pensare che la quantità di
terreno che servirebbe non è superiore
allo zero 5 per cento di tutto quello
che è classificato terreno agricolo
quindi non stiamo parlando di
stravolgimenti ma possiamo farlo
entrambe per esempio solo esempi in
italia e all'estero di campi solari
associate a pascolo in questi le pecore
o gli animali addirittura puliscono
attorno quindi fare un'operazione gratis
mangiando
abbiamo esempi di campi di grano con
impianti che girano e seguono il sole
avendo una produttività del 35 per cento
in più abbiamo impianti che sono delle
serre o delle auto gli impianti che
ombreggiano un po il terreno e possono
produrre anche delle primizie un amico
che fa primizie una serra fotovoltaica
quindi il matrimonio si può fare e in
germania e qui visto che io se fossi lì
davanti almeno attuale ministro quello
che direi e studiate bene quello che
fanno i tedeschi ingerman che non tutte
perde quello che luccica in germania ma
molte cose verdi in germania ci stanno
in germania annunciato le fonti
rinnovabili come mezzo di sostegno alle
imprese agricole
quindi diventa un reddito energetico e
quindi c'è una maggiore residenza
economica a rimanere sul territorio ci
sono vantaggi ambientali si si possono
fare anche sul
sugli specchi d'acqua sopra sopra di sé
nelle dighe dove c'è l'acqua e anche qui
abbiamo un vantaggio che la efficienza
degli impianti aumenta perché il fresco
le fa lavorare meglio
ci sono diversi diciamo impatti
ambientali positivi è primo ma questi
sistemi trattengono l'umidità del suolo
e nel mezzogiorno d'italia il
cambiamento climatico la crisi climatica
mette in crisi i propri terreni
cioè la fertilità dei terreni e mese mi
dava grande peso ma certamente
inaridimento è possibile far convivere
questi impianti e con l'api cultura
perché in questi impianti e ci va alla
gente non ci saranno pesticidi ci
potranno essere piante all'apicoltura
può fiorire l'uso del posto abbiamo
detto è il suo alla galleggiante rimedio
diminuisce l'elaborazione tanto che è un
sistema che in india viene usato perché
in india ad un problema enorme di acqua
e quindi la copertura solare dei canali
fa sì che ci sia meno acqua che si leva
che evapora e poi c'è una novità che sta
arrivando anche aziende italiane stanno
lavorando sull'eolico galleggiante a
mare a c'è molto più vento e l'eolico
gambin giant e supera il limite di quel
fastidio che io non condivido di vedere
qualche eco c'è quello su piattaforme
petrolifere nessuno ha protestato per le
pale voli che tutti protestano ma con
l'eolico capeggiano che si fa oltre la
diciamo l'orizzonte e si possono
utilizzare sono smara impianti molto più
potenti questa è una pala messa in
portogallo da 8 mega watt e quattro i
danesi stanno già testando la palla 14
megawatt si possono creare delle
centrali eoliche galleggianti che
consentono di fare anche una cosa
importante cioè eliminare aree di mare
da altre attività distruttive come per
esempio la pesca a strascico perché
sotto la brava galleggianti ci stanno i
cavi elettrici che portò reti cia quindi
tutto unindustria
che può occupare molto persona quando il
nostro scenario spingendo quindi
possiamo avere il doppio dvd occupati
nel settore occupati diretti nel settore
energetico che sono poco più 80.000
potremmo arrivare a 163 mila nel 2030 e
il costo è largamente quasi del tutto
compensato dai risparmi sulla bolletta
energetica piano bolletta in gran parte
fossile è chiaro che c'è qualcuno che
magari non è molto apporto ad andare
così perosa
ma si può andare più veloce questo
avrebbe una fede di vantaggi e ripeto
dovremo uscire dal dibattito ideologico
suonare a terra o sulle pale eoliche
vanno fatte bene vanno inserite bene ci
vuole
bisogna tornare a un architettura
industriale ma il paesaggio cambierà il
paesaggio cambierà perché la crisi
climatica lo farà cambiare in maniera
drammatica e quindi chi oggi pensa che
l'italia un paese museo sbaglia bisogna
saperlo fare bene abbiamo le tecnologie
abbiamo le intelligenza per farlo